LARRY ARNN: The stakes are the
stakes of human freedom, which
depends upon a view
of human nature
and the government that's
appropriate to that.
The greatest political science
started with the classics
when they began to
study the regimes,
and the worst of all the
kinds of regimes is tyranny.
The rule is in the
interest of the ruler
and that means that the
others are held by force.
They're in greater or
lesser states of rebellion
all the time.
In the 20th century, a new
word was invented for tyranny.
They called it totalitarianism.
In the Soviet Union,
what happens, right?
Your kids have to go to school.
If they don't, you're arrested.
But then what have
they taught in school?
They're taught to inform on you.
People live in terror
of their own children
because the children are young
and they can't and so they
go to school and they
hear authoritative things.
And you'd be afraid to
tell the children not
to believe what's in
school because how can you
trust a 10-year-old not
to repeat what you said,
and to the extent that you can
teach them things like that,
you are depriving them
of their childhood.
That's totalitarianism.
I don't myself think that it's
really different in principle
than ancient tyranny, which is
also at war with human nature.
The classic books
raised the question,
how can a tyrant
perpetuate himself,
because they don't last
very long, these tyrannies.
People don't like them,
and a famous story
repeated by Aristotle
that they do it
by lopping off everything
tall, everything excellent,
everything superior.
A tyrant stands in a field of
grain and lops off all the top
higher heads of grain.
And that point, you
can't have friendship,
you can't have philosophy,
you can't have faith,
because those are
all things that
look both closer
inside the human being,
not just to the tyrant, and
look above the tyrant, too.
And Hitler and Stalin--
just like the great Greek
tyrants and the Roman ones--
they suppress everything
private and everything high.
Except now what changes is the
scale is so much better bigger
and it becomes plausible
that you could actually
remake the world and then
the use of technology
makes it ever more
potentially intense.
About 60 million people were
killed in the war, about half
of them soldiers, sailors,
and airmen, and about half
of them civilians.
That's three times as much
is the First World War.
The body count is just massive.
There are big reasons why the
war is so severe for civilians,
first of all, because technology
and accumulated wealth
make it possible to wage
a more total kind of war
even than was waged in the First
World War, which was incredibly
terrible and unprecedented.
And then the second
thing is there
was a mass-produced, organized
effort to murder people,
whole categories of people.
Whole races of people,
whole professions of people.
Nobody had ever seen
anything like that before.
There's an organized
attempt at mass slaughter.
That's totalitarianism.
One of the most articulate, and
to my mind, finest human beings
who ever left was
Winston Churchill,
who was a friend of freedom.
Parliamentary democracy,
freedom under a Constitution,
Freedom with restraint.
Every person, he loved to quote
can live by no man's leave
beneath the law however
humble that person is born.
The government is to be
accountable to the people.
Churchill said that
there's always two options.
Are the people going to
belong to the government
or is the government going
to belong to the people?
He just repeated
that all his life,
and he thought that these great
totalitarian tyrannies, which
he thought that the extremist
movements in his own country,
including the socialist party
that he opposed all his life
and was beaten by in
1945, echoed in a milder
form the same thing as these
tyrannies, because they, too,
had this sort of notion that we
can perfect the society if we
just assemble more power
in the people who lead it.
So it is a great
contest, and it's
confused between these two
ways of looking at the world.
And they really do
amount to whether you
have a picture of the human soul
that it's free and therefore
entitled to govern itself,
which means never to be governed
except with its consent.
Different than from horses
and dogs and all the things
that we use for pets or this
view that, no, in the end,
we're collective being
shaped by history
and now we're going
to appoint some of us
to get control of the
effort to shape history.
And so the stakes are the
stakes of human freedom, which
depends upon a view
of human nature
and the government that's
appropriate to that.
And that battle still goes on.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
SPEAKER: Thank you for watching.
We hope you're enjoying
our highlight series
and invite you to explore our
complete course on the Second
World wars.
All of Hillsdale
College's online courses
are free and for everyone
who loves to learn.